hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor and today we're going to talk
about hydrant zones and my bazooms but
to understand them first we need to
review briefly mitochondria mitochondria
are organelles that carry out essential
metabolic functions in eukaryotic cells
so remember that eukaryotic cells are
cells that are found in multicellular
organisms like plants and animals and
fungi there's also many unicellular
eukaryotes various kinds of parasites
and algae for example and and so these
are distinct from prokaryotic cells like
bacteria and so it's the eukaryotic
cells that have the organelles like
mitochondria and some of the metabolic
functions of these mitochondria
carry-out include aerobic respiration
which is probably the function you're
most familiar with so arabic respiration
is where oxygen is that final electron
acceptor and so it's respiration that
occurs using the electronegative
properties of oxygen another major
metabolic function is heme biosynthesis
heme is a critical compound for a lot of
different kinds of proteins including
catalysis cytochromes myoglobin
hemoglobin those kinds of things and
then also the final function we're gonna
talk about today is iron sulfur cluster
assembly an iron sulfur clusters are
important in various redox proteins
including those in the electron
transport chain that is being used in
aerobic respiration so that's why
mitochondria are important now some
eukaryotes they don't have a fully
functional mitochondria that do all of
these things and these are primarily
anaerobic types of eukaryotes that don't
use oxygen or oxygen
even be toxic for them and instead of
having these fully functioning
mitochondria they only have a couple of
different forms of degenerate
mitochondria what this means is that
sometime in their evolutionary history
they had fully functioning mitochondria
but over time they didn't need those
functions and ultimately lost them
having now these degenerate mitochondria
that only have a subset of the original
functions this is an example of
reductive evolution so that's an example
of reductive evolution where you have
sort of a more complex thing become a
more simple thing over the period of
evolution and of course that's true
again just for some eukaryotes most
eukaryotes still have their fully
functioning mitochondria including
humans so now let's talk about two of
these types of degenerate mitochondria
hydrogenous ohms and midas zones will
start with hydrogenous ohms these are
found in species of trichomonas
including trichomonas vaginalis which
causes the sexually transmitted
infection to come in ISS it's also found
that some other species of fungi and
delegates usually hydrogen ohms like
their own genome so it's important to
realize that why while mitochondria as
well as chloroplasts another organelle
actually have their own genome inside
eukaryotic cells hydrogenous ohms
typically don't have their own genome
they've lost that during the course of
this reductive evolution when it just
wasn't needed anymore
they do still produce some ATP which is
also the goal of aerobic respiration up
here some carbon dioxide is produced at
the same time and there's also a bye
product of hydrogen gas so h2 gas and
that is where they get their name
hydrogenous tones because they generate
this hydrogen by-product so now let's
talk about the second kind of degenerate
mitochondria that is midas owns these
are found in species of Giardia like
Giardia lamblia which is also known as
giardia intestinalis as well as antony
best pieces for example
entamoeba histolytica both the Giardia
and to me buff species that I mentioned
are common intestinal parasites you get
them either by drinking contaminated
water or eating contaminated food and so
they have important repercussions for
human health also there are some other
anaerobes and micro era files that have
Midas ohms these might as ohms also do
not have their own genome and unlike
hydrogenous ohms they actually do not
produce their own ATP now all three of
these meaning the mitochondria
hydrogenous ohms and the Midas ohms all
three carry out this iron sulfur cluster
assembly this is one of the main pieces
of evidence that suggests common
evolutionary history again meaning that
Midas owns and might assume that
hydrogenous ohms descended from
mitochondria so way back early on in the
history of the eukaryotic lineage when
cells like trichomonas ancestors and
Giardia and to me the ancestors split
off from other eukaryotic cells like
those that were going to lead to animals
and plants and fungi they they they
already have these mitochondria and then
over time their might
Maria became degenerate losing functions
forming the modern-day hydrogenous tones
and - cells so we also know that this
sort of degenerative process this
reductive evolution has happened
multiple times so it happened in the
trichomonas lynnie and it happened in
the Giardia and sameba lineage it also
happened for some fungi and some other
ciliates and some other anaerobes in my
era file so it's happened multiple times
if you are interested in learning a
little bit more about things like
anaerobes and micro era files and
aerobic respiration that i've got some
videos you can check out including on
bacterial oxygen preferences which will
tell you more about these terms here as
well as an introduction to cellular
respiration where you can learn more
about this aerobic respiration process
and that's it for today thanks for
watching biology professor